in three separate races over a three-day
meeting at Aintree three horses would
lose their lives dark Raven and voice
special and Hill 16. it's an
unacceptable tally for the animal rights
activists who stormed the Racecourse in
the hope of halting the world-renowned
Grand National at the climax of the
festival
now the British Horse Racing authority
has confirmed it will work with the
Racecourse to analyze in painstaking
detail exactly what happened the
campaigners say they are preparing for
further action
unfortunately we weren't successful in
saving the life of the horse Hill 16.
but what we did manage to do is start
this public conversation that's so
important about the way that we're
treating animals the activists may not
have succeeded in stopping the event but
they did manage to delay the start with
at least one gluing themselves to a jump
the jumps are notoriously high and 62
horses have died at the Aintree Festival
since the year 2000 four of them last
year but changes have been made in
recent years Julie Harrington the chief
executive of the BHA said
British racing works tirelessly to
improve the sports safety record and
reduce avoidable risk
we respect the right of anyone to hold
views about our sport but we robustly
condemn The Reckless and potentially
harmful actions of a handful of people
in disrupting the race at a time when
horses were in the parade ring
fatalities are said to have fallen by
more than a third over the past 20 years
because it's a sport that's evolving
everyone is determined to make it as
safe as possible defenses are less
exacting they have they don't have the
the drop fence the the the drop Landings
which which make them tricky they do not
have the solid foundations inside them
they are far more forgiving so they I it
is a much safer course
the campaign group animal Rising said
118 protesters were arrested in all on
Saturday it's likely there'll be more to
come as they fight to see jump racing
banned for good
Emma birchley Sky News